when there's completely senseless
violence or when a woman is sexually
abused in public it doesn't make
headlines the same way that a man
defending citizens does and that's for a
very simple reason because the media
wants us to know that if we stand up for
ourselves against violent criminals we
will be punished for it I mean this is
by Design they want criminals to overrun
the cities they want to make life as
untenable as possible because this is
something Marxist virtually always do
when they're trying to upset the social
order make things as unstable for people
as possible
just generally make cities unlivable I
suppose it's like the ice cream shop in
Seattle that's suing now because their
business suffered a loss of Revenue when
the autonomous Zone the Capitol Hill
autonomous Zone Chas was established but
the same ice cream shop was calling for
them to defund the police that's right
yeah